i was born and raised in new jersey so
this this movie really really spoke to
me
yeah i was born in uh new brunswick grew
up in new brunswick uh rutgers that's
brian
foreign country that's where we shop for
the first scene in clerks brian
falling out of a closet we shot in new
brunswick amazing yeah yeah i went i
went to rutgers my parents work at
rutgers
i'm in jersey city as we speak uh so
yeah this entire story really spoke to
me but i'm interested in the story
because
you know your career is obviously not
over uh
it's clearly right i don't know it
depends who you ask vincent
for a long time for a lot i guess the
opinion is out there
but like you're still working so i'm
wondering uh for both of you why
this was the time to sort of you know
take stock and look back
when it's not you know you're not at a
point where you can only look back so
i'm wondering why this was the time to
sort of take stock of it
we're at we're hitting the 25 year point
and that's traditionally
a good like it just seemed and
kevin's kind of career was going on this
completely fascinating other path
and i.e unsuccessful yeah
i mean look it's it's that thing wait
five years like everything kevin does he
but
right now he's at the end of a i think a
very fascinating time
where he's kind of gone on this
incredible [ __ ] journey and so for
the first 25 years i think it was best
just like okay
like you know and i was around for a lot
of it so i was like okay
this seems like a good time to kind of
um take a look back at it and just be
like all right well there was this
um and then you know and hopefully in 20
i mean i won't be alive but in 25 years
there'll be another
kind of 25 years to look at but it
seemed like a good increment
of us all malcolm let's be honest that's
optimistic
he uh he honestly this wouldn't happen
without malcolm i
if another person had come to me and
said we wanted to do a documentary about
you i would have been like too soon like
way too soon
and i've had documentaries about the
stuff i've done like you know on the
dvds like the snowball effect on clerks
10.
so we've definitely had look backs and
whatnot and so there was no pressing
need to do it but malcolm has been
around for this entire journey and he's
an
interesting person to capture it because
i didn't grow up with him it's not like
he's muse or brian johnson or walter
flanagan i met
malcolm like the way we're meeting
malcolm interviewed me for film threat
at the toronto film festival like back
at 1994 before the movie right before
clerks came out theatrically
so we struck up a kinship and whatnot
and i helped him get his first movie
made and financed it and whatnot and
we've been friends
ever since and he's he's
unlike most of my friends who are like
blood or something like that who are
there from childhood
malcolm has always been like you know
acutely unafraid of telling me
when i've lost it [ __ ] up when i've
lost the threat of the conversation who
do you think you are
but never also the person that held me
back because malcolm's also been the guy
that has encouraged me to like spin that
plate
spin that plate and stuff like i don't
get to do all the weird things i've done
without malcolm over the years like
letting me know where i'm in the
business because
when you are doing yourself
masturbatorily professionally for a
living
you can't really look up and figure out
where you are because there's no
one to compare it to you can't be like
oh well ed burns is doing the same thing
let me see how ed burns is doing so
there's
for me it was always tough to figure out
am i successful or not
malcolm as an outsider who's also an
insider
has always been able to tell me when i'm
working
in the culture and when i'm and i'm not
and he's been
painfully accurate in all those times
and stuff so he's a guy that like
for better or for worse knows how to
read my career without the added
interest of like
i'm his mother you know or something
like that like
malcolm has almost like played me like
an avatar for many years and as much as
like
this is what i would do if i was you
with this kind of access with this kind
of thing
and the one of the greatest things he
ever did was never
told me to be the one thing he was never
like you know concentrate on your
[ __ ] film craft and get good at that
and [ __ ] all these other distractions
malcolm was always like do the other
things like make those like
why wouldn't you lean into that he's
going it's like if you could either be a
filmmaker or you could be like a rock
star and he's like you know filmmakers
fun but like
you have people who are willing to like
just watch you talk you don't even need
the movies anymore
so having him when he suggested he was
like i
i could do a documentary about your
first 25 years it came off of this book
discussion we were having and he was
like
instead of writing a book i could take a
camera with me interview these people
and it could be a documentary and i
produced
documentaries malcolm's made before so i
knew he knew how to do that
i also knew he had a very particular
insight where you know he would
he'd be unafraid to go warts and all and
[ __ ] like that
and and i plus i'd be completely
comfortable
with him and giving him access like if
you ever watch the
interview tapes it's like this malcolm
goes
so 25 years and then i talked for six
hours and malcolm
like you know i'm a very easy mark to
get an interview out of and stuff so
it was the right guy asking at the right
time as he said when he first asked
we were coming close to like the 25th
anniversary of clerks or something like
that
and so you know it felt like all right i
guess there's enough time
to look back and then when i almost
dropped dead from the heart attack
malcolm's face lit up like
all money
you know what's funny the first i just
remembered now
you know the first time i ever mentioned
doing a documentary on you
was after me and you walked out of the
richard link later
a documentary richard linklater at
sundance yes and i was like
hey man i want to be the one if if
somebody's telling your story
it does happen yeah well i'm curious
because you know i'm curious about
making this movie because you
you'd assume that the the goal is to do
something illuminating about kevin smith
the person
but kevin smith the person has been the
public brand
for ever so i'm wondering like how do
you how do you dive deeper
into into how do you dive deeper
into the shallowest man
you know that's that's the brand uh how
do you get past
what people already know i think what i
brought to the table was that just
because i've been around like a bad
stink
most of the time um like i have
i have my own relationships with like
kevin's wife with kevin's friends with
his daughter
his mother like they know me as me so
i i basically talking to them they
trusted me so like
like harley like harley's interview like
it it made me smile so much because she
wasn't
like i love that she's just like that
was before she was cast in tarantino
movie like she's just like no i [ __ ]
love tarantino
like so through the intimacy i had in
that world
um it basically i was you know i could
talk to people and i could get you know
i could get everybody's take on it
maybe in a way that other people
couldn't this really does revisit
times in my life i remember these movies
coming out and so it's interesting to
hear you talk about
um at what points you returned to the
familiar stuff like why you did
clerks too why you wanted to return to
malcolm i'm wondering
because if i'm not mistaken you you have
balls in the air right now for
clerks 3 and mall rats too and i'm
wondering what it means for you to be
revisiting that
at this point in your life like after
the document oh i'll be honest with you
pre-heart attack it was too dangerous
because you're always supposed to be
moving forward in your career and
post heart attack though like you know
as far as i'm concerned
i was dead i died on that table like is
luck of the irish or or the skill of dr
leidenheim
that pulled me out of a widowmaker 80
percent of the people
get killed by so at that point i feel
like and
my wife hates when i say it but it's
true like i honestly feel like i'm
living on borrowed time i was like
it ended at that table everything after
that
is [ __ ] gravy because i came to a
place of peace on the table where i was
like you know what
if there's an 80 chance i'm dying
tonight like
what do you think about the entire
journey and i reached a place of utter
peace where i was like you know you had
a good life you did some cool [ __ ] you
had a great family you were loved by
your parents you
had your own [ __ ] kid and wife and
stuff like that like what do you what do
you
what are you worried about if it ends it
ends and i was like totally ready to go
not in an emo death metal like i want to
die kind of way but just like you know
what i get it
and then all of a sudden i lived and
[ __ ] and so from that point forward
you're just kind of like playing on
house money
so for me i'm like i'm going to lean
into this stuff that
i deeply care about you know i was
always kind of like doing my own thing
but
there are definitely governing factors
like you know i didn't do as many usq
movies as i wanted to
because i remember reading on the
internet people being like oh he's doing
another one of those interconnected
movies and eventually i was shamed out
of it you know where i was like i
shouldn't do that
now i don't care now i'm just like oh
i'm gonna if i can get away with clerks
19 i will like
so it's so it's very but i also came to
grips with a long time ago
that i've been in the nostalgia business
probably since 1995.
like the you know clerks is the only
real like original and finger on the
pulse
of the moment thing that i ever said
most everything else i do is predicated
on
looking back you know even mall rats is
like comic book fandom is constantly
about something that happened back then
not what's happening right now
not what's happening in the future comic
book men when we did the show like i was
really faced it when we were doing comic
book man because i'm like
this is a show about middle-aged men
talking about toys they used to have
when they were children like
we are in the nostalgia business right
now my biggest project coming up this
year other than clerks three
is masters of the universe at netflix
that's
exactly that is it's not only is it
nostalgic
we're not even like reinventing it it's
a sequel to the old cartoon so like
i'm in the nostalgia business and i
pitched something recently we were
pitching this
show uh that was kind of like uh you
know we're doing these movies pop-ups so
we're pitching a show about
like a reality show about that and
somebody who i was talking to like at
the network was like i'll be honest with
you
you're good for our brand because you
really represent nostalgia she's like i
hope i don't
offend you by that did you kidding me
that's how i make money in this world
yeah whatever works it literally is like
people like fincher
you know and people like jj they're
always looking forward or
in the in the moment if not in the
future everything i do is predicated on
some [ __ ] happen to you in your 20s
or when you're a child now and i'm okay
with that like i
i don't have to break new ground and
stuff like you know i i had indie film
under my belt
and i had i got to talk about comics
before the whole world did and
podcasting i was early for and stuff
like that maybe i'm getting into crypto
maybe i'll be early there but generally
speaking like i ain't looking to
you know be like i'm going to shatter
expectations and stuff like that
i you know you could if you look at the
arc of my career and you could see it in
this movie
i you know i i i've always been kind of
turned in like you know clerks is about
me and my friends that's literally what
my life looked like back then
and so since it worked and since
everything i've ever done that's kind of
personally based has worked
i just lean into that and right now as a
middle-aged man nostalgia is a big
arrow in the quiver man to be able to
pull out the fire
uh while i have you i do want to ask you
about something that i think i've only
heard about uh
slightly rumored and speaking of
nostalgia uh is is gerard way
still scoring clerk's three i i don't
know if he'll be able to score that's
based on a time question i told him that
i wanted him to do the whole score and
he was like
you know oh my god i'm flattered he's a
fan he's a jersey guy as well
but he told i did tell him i was like
look if you can't do the whole movie i
at least need the opening i need the
welcome to the black parade is my
opening track and he was like
you have it done and done great so
that hits me in a very specific
nostalgia oh you know what i'm saying
and also me
and as much as i didn't live through it
like you did but my kid lived through it
and i lived with my kid as she was going
through it so
i love that song and i love that the
boys are from new jersey
but it also has nostalgic and emotional
resonance for me because
my kid was so that's how she started
developing your own personality that's
when she stopped being my kid
and was this you know oh a person with
her own interest she likes this mcr what
is this
and helped make me more relevant by
being like here's a band that people
listen to today dad as opposed to run
dmc
so you know it helped she helped as well
dragged me into the future in a little
bit
um i so like i said i'm from new jersey
and i've always been interested in this
like
romanticized idea of like the small town
new jersey story and like in
a lot of ways like it's i feel like this
movie is a form of that
even like wanda vision is going to new
jersey now which is so interesting to me
and i'm wondering like what
why that's so appealing to people like
this very specific sort of uh
small town new jersey success story or
just you know just the story of small
town new jersey and what
why people find that i honestly feel at
this age where i am
the the new jersey small town story has
replaced the middle america
story because new jersey very much feels
more like america than middle america
new jersey is
new jersey has this incredible identity
that
was forged in the fire of growing up
next to manhattan
so no matter what you do in new jersey
no matter what greatness
you can achieve it will always be in the
shadow
of something far larger than yourself
it's like growing up with
you know what being one of the gretzky
kids and wayne is your brother it's like
no matter what you do people are gonna
be like yeah man but
but new york they set the time new
jersey you guys got the nuclear waste
so any sort of identity factor
um comes from this kind of like chip on
your shoulder
ideal of hey we matter
too you know you're the scrappy younger
sibling
who will constantly have to prove
yourself for the rest of your life
and that's bred into us i i feel not
you know they don't teach it in school
but it's just such a part of the state's
identity and because of that i think it
makes you
try harder and then what you find is a
lot of people want to get out of the
state
i was never one of those people i was
never like i gotta get out of here i
eventually did my wife dragged me out
but out here in the business i don't
know if it's the same for you but i've
encountered
every fourth or fifth person is from new
jersey so it breeds
people who are ambitious maybe that's
because they're like i want to get out
or maybe it's because like you have to
constantly prove yourself
over and over again if you're from new
jersey it's just built into who you are
and i think that constant struggle for
identity
to be like i'm here and i matter plays
incredibly well
across the world like it's an american
story
and it doesn't get much more american
than new jersey it's the crossroads
of the east coast like a lot of people
who work in manhattan
live in new jersey you know so it's like
they go somewhere for a big adventure
but when they put their head on the
pillow at night it's someplace
real like and i think and honestly it's
credibility you cannot
[ __ ] buy in this world so many people
have given me
benefit of the doubt or welcomed me into
their world be simply
by geographical lottery the luck of
where i was born
for some reason they feel it makes you
more authentic and and i hope they're
absolutely right i feel more authentic
but i don't know who i'm basing or
comparing that against but i just know
my new jersey roots it's kind of in you
you just constantly have to prove
yourself over
it's to be honest with you in early in
my career is exhausting
if you look at my early career i'm
constantly like battling back and stuff
that is so [ __ ] new jersey like
obviously over the course of the last 15
years i've been a stoner
and that has like kind of softened the
jersey
you know but with jersey you're always
got your dander up and you're always
ready to prove yourself
um that's just it's in your blood yeah
someone named
vinnie from new jersey i get that
pushback a lot uh
so yeah just just one last question for
for you guys i'm wondering just sort of
since
this is a documentary made by someone
who knows you personally and i'm
wondering
if there's a moment particularly i don't
know in the in the interview process
you're gathering all the stuff that that
you you personally malcolm found a new
insight about kevin that you didn't know
before or a moment where you were like
wow that's that's illuminating for me
and i know this guy
it was basically kind of the
zealougness of it all like even though
being around it all and seeing it
when you actually kind of like throw it
off on paper and kind of be like
oh [ __ ] like internet check
like marvel check like
it's incred like podcasting check it was
a really
kind of it's a very impressive you know
it's a very impressive track record like
kevin's kind of been
uh ahead of things and literally
um i think the most important part to
say about it is that
it's been following his own thing it's
not like he sits there and he's like
i want to [ __ ] i want to be on top of
the new thing he's like this interests
me
i'm going to go this way and it
infuriates people
it confuses people but ultimately he
he's usually proven right
like and and like not about yoga hosers
that that
that one i'm still smart and funny you
always get one you always get
one bump in the road that's the
exception that proves the rule malcolm's
talked about
that's what i learned amazing i think
that's actually
all the time i get with you guys but
again thank you so much man movie spoke
to me on a very personal level i
appreciate it so bad did you enjoy it
of course yeah i did i did and i was
like places that you knew because you're
north jersey but did you see [ __ ] where
you're like i know that i mean i've been
to red bank a thousand times you know
what i mean like i
when i'm going down to seaside or
ashbury park we stop we stop in red bank
or you know i've spent
many a fourth of july in red bank it's
that's hey with the fireworks
exactly yeah been there a million as a
new jersey person was walt one of your
favorite characters in the documentary
it's so funny like people don't
understand how familiar that is
like i'm just like yeah all of this
that's people i know it's people looking
at yeah
that's i love i mean i love like also my
favorite people in the whole universe
and i love that just like
walt's wall yeah you know there's
there's no
there's no stopping wall from me and
wall and so i have the privilege of
to sit down and talk to him he just like
when i explained to him kevin's pot use
and like that was all genuine like that
wasn't a setup where he is
there's no way he's been spoken for 10
years straight you're like he's been
high every day for 10 years he's like
what i found so ironic about it is that
dude was literally like
nobody could do the same thing for 10
years and he's literally sitting in the
comic book story
he's been doing it for a decade that
didn't
well again thank you guys thank you so
much